friend of mine from the NFL Network you
can follow him on Twitter at Shawn
O'Hara 60 see him every single Wednesday
on NFL playbook at 6:30 p.m. Eastern
Time and a Super Bowl champion that
Chris Brockman accused of holding every
single damn time this year its Shawn
O'Hara how are you Shawn
I'm doing well how are you I'd like
clockwork that comes up I didn't bring
it up I mean we I said yesterday I was
not gonna bring it up oh I'm sorry is it
is this now awkward so what is
technically does that mean you brought
it up since you said it yesterday he did
say yesterday I'm not bringing it up
this is bringing it up but not in front
of you write this up in front of you
right
the greedy Bob said the longer you stay
with all due respect you could say
whatever you like 14 times on that play
that's clutching God she says the guy
but more Super Bowls in eating yeah I
know I know right
Patriots being overlooked this year do
you think that was a question we asked
on NFL gameday morning with no hint of
irony on Sunday yeah it's funny that we
could say that every year
because I feel like every year we talk
in the offseason about man how are they
gonna do it I mean they didn't they
didn't get this guy they don't have that
guy this guy's heard this guy's missing
and then every year they're hosting the
AFC changeup game so I don't they're
just they're not a hype team like
there's no hype in the building there's
no hype around them they just dismantled
the Minnesota Vikings I mean they made
Kirk Cousins look pedestrian on third
down it was remarkable the game plan of
what they did what is the what was the
game plan because we're gonna probably
see Seattle do it again and we just had
a fan of the Vikings from Washington
State Colin and it sounds like he's on
one of the many bridges out there and
ready to ready to off himself based on
the cousins being there on a big
contract over the next couple years
after they brought him in to win win the
big game like that one yeah and like
this coming Monday night now in Kirk
Cousins defense I call it stadium the
Bermuda Triangle
that's where offenses go and get lost
like nobody knows what happens to them
but things happen there that don't
happen to teams anywhere else in the NFL
but I mean butchered snaps I mean Ryan
Tannehill shotgun snaps going over his
head it's
it's unbelievable how they do that but
Kurt cousins you mention playbook I was
working on a little project yeah
yesterday okay
third down I think they were three for
13 on third down
the Patriots basically said we're gonna
take out them Thielen away from you on
third down we're gonna double them they
bracket in them they jammed on at the
line
basically took Adam Thielen out of out
of the game on third down and they had
no answer something else has got a win
so and nobody could and they put their
best corner Gilmore on on on Diggs
doubled Thielen and said now what you
got and Kirk had nowhere to go with the
ball he ended up eating it out to get
three sacks they ended up getting home
with some good pressure they do a great
job of that it's it's always so fun to
watch them every week because nobody
morphs better week to weekend the
Patriots well it's right it's
year-to-year it's week to week it's game
a game it's snap to snap yeah even last
week against the Jets I mean they just
went down there and they said we're
gonna run our we're gonna bring our
offensive lineman we're gonna just run
the ball you know 200 yards rushing it
was funny Zimmer during the week leading
up to last week's game against the
Vikings said admittedly goes up to you
know to be honest they're using
cordarrelle Patterson way better than we
ever did it's perfect example yeah okay
so we're down we're down to James White
running the football mmm because
Michelle's hurt and Rex Burkhead was on
the mid-season IR what are we gonna do
oh yeah there's Cordero pilots it so who
in the buildings like while we use
Patterson you know he's about 240 he's
about to forties never run the ball but
let's give him a shot yeah it's crazy
how its its it you know hey we're out of
we're out of defensive backs let's uh
let's see what Troy Brown could do back
there yeah I mean they've been doing it
for two decades why doesn't know what
why do you know other teams do stuff
like that it's it's not like just a
couple other teams do it like no other
teams do it like them and it's
remarkable that the players they don't
just play but they play well they they
go into the game and it's man who knows
what to expect with this guy yeah I mean
he's never done this before and then he
goes out and has a good game I mean
Cordell Patterson was averaging like six
yards of carry during one of those games
never done it before it's enough to make
a good
solid citizen hold during a crucial
Superbowl play against him right no
actually they're on in Miami and that's
their you want Togo upper million
triangles yeah that is that for the the
Patriots God with the exception of that
500-yard Brady to Welker night to open
the season many many years ago yeah
right it's a Monday night right to open
up the season other than that that's
just that's weird things happen in Miami
yeah that's where Brady's saying you
know what I want to bring my own
footballs to the game I'm serious he
that's him in Miami and Peyton Manning
this is back in like oh seven where they
went to the league and say you know
we're you need to change the rules where
footballs are being provided of both
teams in a home stadium and the league
basically said bring your own damn
footballs which is always setting up as
the the future but you know you know all
right let's take a break that's another
conversation how many how many
conspiracy theories can I throw out
there few all right let's take a break
we're gonna ask our poll question of ask
the poll question before we go to break
so you can think about it Chris Brockman
who's most likely to miss the playoffs
in the NFC missed the playoffs in the
NFC Vikings Eagles Panthers Cowboys seal
I have my choice I have yet to put my
thumb on the scale Shawn O'Hara will do
that and then I want to ask you about
teams to make a run and I've got a team
on that list that I like a lot to make a
run as well in these playoffs that's
coming up next
also still to come Urban Meyer's
farewell to Ohio State press conference
top of the next hour when Bruce Feldman
of Fox Sports and the athletic joins us
to discuss that piece of news today back
with Shawn O'Hara on the Rich Eisen show
your phone calls 844 204 rich and more
still to come
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
Shawn O'Hara check him out on the NFL
Network tonight you know every Wednesday
on NFL Network's NFL playbook at Shawn
O'Hara 60 we've got Bruce Feldman of the
athletic and Fox Sports joining us at
the top of the next hour when Urban
Meyer says farewell to Ohio State
handing the reins off to Ryan day after
this year's Rose Bowl so Shawn the poll
question ask it once again of Shawn
O'Hara before he answers it Chris
Brockman who's most likely to miss the
playoffs in the NFC Vikings Eagles
Panthers Cowboys Seahawks I want to say
you you want me to say go ahead I'm
gonna say the Cowboys come on I must say
the Eagles find a way to beat the
Cowboys next week and then go on a run i
I think Dallas if I mean I still have
questions where do you find that
confidence has been dak has been since
Amari Cooper showed up with the
exception of that Tennessee Titans game
much more relaxed and much more
effective he can't he needs to hold on
to the ball in the pocket much better
yeah that's where I think I would I
would disagree with that the Cowboys
front seven is no joke and that's not
going anywhere that'll stop anybody as
we saw last Thursday night yeah they
look good that Saints game nobody
predicted that happening and that's true
not even Irv as much as he was happy
after the game he paid I don't he was he
was but he was doing the the reverse
jinx by choosing the snow and I'm with
you on Cooper Cooper has added that
go-to guy if I got me in coverage I got
a guy that can I know I can count on
yeah but that's not enough and and I and
that's why I think Philly
I think Carson Wentz has done a better
job on third down you know we showed the
interception down there in a red zone
for the most part he's done a better job
in the red zone dak has trouble seven
sacks that's what I couldn't get over
the seven he he and Eli going into last
week were the most sacked quarterbacks
in the NFL and a lot of it is because
dak is not doing a good job when there's
nobody open getting to his second and
third progressions and he's holding on
to the ball he's burping the baby that's
what's leading to a lot of sacs and when
he does feel pressure he's backing up it
looks like Cam Newton from a couple
years ago he's stepping back
right into the rush and where
everybody's going and he's done it way
too many times this year that's what
really concerns me
they're defense look phenomenal yeah I
know hold the Saints to ten points I
mean that's unbelievable and so is Zeke
that's why I feel I mean I I can't
believe I'm saying this but I would take
the Cowboys not only to perform better
than the Eagles down the stretch I think
that they they may even win a playoff
game because I think they're probably
gonna wind up with a better record than
the Bears and finished third and avoid
the team that I think out of this entire
group and I'm throwing the Bears in that
mix if I threw the Bears in this mix the
team that's most likely to go on a run
in the NFC playoffs out of this whole
group I think is Seattle I love the way
our play I love the way that they're
running it I love the way that Russell
Wilson is performing he's not running
for his life all the touchdowns are not
because of his running for his life
making plays I have to give the credit
to Brian Schottenheimer who I thought
was an Arnold glance in an uninspired
choice for offensive coordinator he has
been terrific and the defense with Earl
Thomas now no longer there I thought
they would fall apart there they look
like they're rolling they look like
they're not just winning I don't see
hawk John that worried we we come to
know yeah they're not just winning games
getting their teeth their long game is a
threat Baldwin is a number one yeah and
Damon Moore the wide receiver the
seventh pick out of eastern central you
know Oklahoma that nobody has ever heard
of he's kind of become a little bit of a
go-to guy for us so would you agree with
me that that's the team Adam I can go on
a run actually in the playoff I think
Seattle is a very dangerous team you
know you mentioned being portable that
defense even without our own Bobby
wagner's all over the field he's like
Superman is there getting home with the
pass rush and and I think the fact that
now their offensive line is being more
aggressive they're back to that ratio
when they had Marshawn Lynch they are
they're running the ball 53% of the
times just four guys are playing the
role of Marshawn Lynch it's by committee
yeah but I'm with you on Seattle and I
tell you they're there at physical team
they're well coached team the fact they
went on the road
against was a Carolina just weeks ago I
don't want a clock game which is not
easy to do they roll them and that's the
team I would choose an hour pole clock
yeah well with you I think Carolina I
don't know what the heck's happened then
port Greg Olson looks like he's done
yeah
it gave me forever which would be awful
but great for everybody in the NFL media
business cuz he's built for what you're
doing right now yeah a camp through four
interceptions on the road in against
Tampa they've got two games against the
Saints left I mean I think they're in
trouble what's what's the results as
they currently stand there right now
Carolina leads the way sixty-two percent
I'm with him
Eagles nineteen percent it was an ugly
loss to you mentioned the interception
but the the the offensive line is played
well when they were having their good
stretch Carolina but they look like that
against Tampa yeah and their defensive
has been one of the worst all year and
I'm concerned for Ron Rivera I think the
owners got an itchy trigger finger he's
a guy who's new to ownership and he's
known for his mercurial nature and his
other businesses that allowed him to
afford the Carolina Panthers and I think
this game against the Browns this week
in Cleveland could be as Mike McCarthy
game I'm serious I mean he's let go of a
couple of his rivera let go a couple of
assistants is d-line and defensive back
coach
yeah with four games to go yeah I'm
genuinely concerned about them Shawn
O'Hara here on the Rich Eisen show re is
this the end of Eli no New York for the
Giants
I don't think so they will come back
with Eli Manning next yeah I could see
it happening I know a lot of people the
narrative is I've got the Giants right
now picking seventh overall the Giants
are picking seventh overall right now
and if there's a quarterback right there
you don't think they go on and hop on
that and I mean they very well could but
I also could see the scenario where they
take a quarterback and and and I still
plays okay here you know I don't think
Eli wants to play for another team you
know I think that goes without saying
why would I so I think for people that
have said hey trade him or he wants to
go somewhere else and I don't think so
I know he doesn't want to go somewhere
else no but why means more to him than
people even realize but I thought the
job would give me more voice to that
what do you mean um
I think like playing quarterback in the
NFL and like Eli as a purist his brother
as appears his whole family and they're
there they're all about the Mannings are
pure yeah
yeah that's but IIIi think
wholeheartedly to go to another team and
put on a Jersey after all those years
and everything that he is done for the
organization put into I think would be
hard for him to go do that no I
understand that and that's totally
understandable I'm talking about the
other side of the equation that the
Giants at some point every franchise
struggles to go from one quarterback to
the next I mean every it's coming for
the Patriots yeah you know even even to
go from a goat to a goat in Green Bay
was ugly I mean it's just very rare that
one guy steps down and the other guy
steps in it's coming for the Giants it's
coming down the pike for the Giants and
the question is is when do you do that
and if they finish five and 11 which is
entirely possible
they'd have to lose three out of their
last four and the Giants last four
they're at Mark Sanchez mmm can't
believe I just said that home for
Tennessee at Andrew Luck and
Indianapolis home for Dallas yeah you
don't think the Giants would think twice
or they really would just stay the
course I think they're they're probably
looking for the next quarterback
obviously they're looking down the road
with that but III think that to me I
almost couldn't evaluate Eli in the
first half of the season because the the
office of lines of protection I mean it
was so I mean everything was so
dysfunctional the last few weeks I think
you've really gotten a better
understanding of the fact that he'll I
could still play as he still mr. Rose
yeah there's still times where man it
looks like aw man that that offenses
just out of sync
absolutely there's a number of reasons
for it but I still look at Eli and I
still see a guy that with the game on
the line he could still make that throw
he had he made a great throw to Sterling
Shepherd in this past game against the
Bears I should have been a touchdown
wasn't caught
yeah obviously the the two-minute drive
against the 49ers right they came back
and won that that's what you want out of
your quarterback I don't know that a
rookie quarterback coming in has that
Moxie has that confidence that everybody
can latch on to Eli has that that's
there's value in that and I think if
you're an organization and you have a
guy like Eli any quarterback with that
Moxie with that ability you don't just
cast them aside if you don't have to all
right Sean four weeks to go here who
wins it give me the Super Bowl
prediction and championship four weeks
to go who'd you have Pro part of the
season would you change it right now
yeah in the end of CEI you know I
probably gave a couple of answers you
know you could ask that so many times I
had the Rams and and I liked Atlanta
coming into the season Saints was not to
like about Atlantica yeah I mean I can't
believe what's going on there I mean the
injuries obviously are huge but I think
the Saints are still the best complete
team I think the Rams are are
offensively one of the most gifted teams
defensively they've got some guys and
get out of the quarterback but I think
the Saints are much more physical and
they're much more balanced defensively
so I still think the Saints have a shot
at getting their AFC I'm still waiting
to see the Chiefs how they finish I'm a
little concerned obviously you know the
running back by committee now that could
change their offensive line it actually
played pretty well but the Chiefs
defense has me questioning them right so
I still think that you got to go through
Foxborough you want to get the Super
Bowl well they might not have to so
that's my question to you in the last
minute I have with you is did the Saints
have to be home in order to beat the
Rams and do the payments have to be home
in order to beat the Chiefs I don't
think the Saints have to be I think that
the fact that they they have good
balance now with Ingram and with chimera
and the fact that they have been so
physical up from what their office line
they can they can travel mm-hmm
much better than they have in the past
the Chiefs I think I'm I I want to jump
on board with him I still just don't
know if in the big game in that big
moment what does that team gonna do I
don't feel like there may be as
battle-tested as some of these other
teams yet especially in the AFC when I
look at you know so the way some of
these teams are fitting and finding ways
to finish games good to have you here
brother thanks man I really enjoy our
chats it's good to see you pal you want
to get a workout in yeah sure okay I'll
be at JLB glaza zmei you know I like
that you do that yeah like 20 bucks
although you I see what you're saying
it's different spot I just started
working out there yeah no no wait on the
bar we'll just start with the buck Wow
and then we'll work our way up
I could I could do 125 because I I
proposed this to you a while ago I want
to see you do more on just yeah one 125
people know it good to see you pal each
other at Shawn O'Hara 60 on Twitter Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience